[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Coffee
with a Googler."
I'm here with Sebastian
Thrun, founder of Udacity.
And I wanted to just
hear a little bit more
about the announcements
today in the keynote.
Can you tell us and
share with the world
what you and your team
are doing at Udacity?
SEBASTIAN THURN: Yeah.
We are really,
really pleased to see
that someone took the time to
talk about our new nanodegree.
That is basically a way to
bring education to the world,
to democratize education.
Google, wonderful.
14 great instructors at
Google have teamed up
with my startup company
Udacity to bring education
to the entire world, including
Egypt and many other places.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
Where did you get
the idea for Udacity?
Because you used to
be at Google, right?
SEBASTIAN THURN: I
used to be at Google.
I was a mid-level
manager in Maps
and eventually made
it into Google X
and founded Google X.
And then at some point,
I realized one of the most
important things we have
to do is to provide education to
people-- not just information,
not making just the world's
information accessible,
but we're making the
world's education
accessible and democratize it.
So I took time out,
I started Udacity,
and we have more than
4 million students.
We're doing fine.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's really awesome.
And is the education primarily
focused around developers,
or can you share more about
the breadth of the offerings
that Udacity has?
SEBASTIAN THURN: Yeah.
So the Android nanodegree
with Google to be [INAUDIBLE]
is built and undersigned
by Google, by Peter Lubbers
and his team really
teaches people
to become Android developers.
So if you take the education,
you getting a nanodegree,
you should be able to find a job
in the Valley or in the world.
And in the Valley, we pay
for a good Android developer
easily $100,000 or more
in salary per year.
So it's really meant
to find people a job.
It's projected based.
You do many projects.
You do much less lectures.
There's some classes,
but they're optional.
And it's one of the many
nanodegrees we've launched.
We launched five other ones.
I hate to say, in
iOS, we have one.
But we also have data
engineering and programming,
and all around computer science.
So all that kind of stuff.
The kind of stuff that
we teach is the type
you would like to hire.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And I think that's
a game changer.
Bringing more people
into the industry
and having this
industry knowledge
really helps more people come
into our industry faster.
Because I know that
in the next 20 years--
we have so many
jobs, and we're going
to need them filled by amazing
people around the world.
SEBASTIAN THURN: Yeah.
And this is the kind
of stuff-- I mean,
I'm a former university
professor from Stanford,
and this is the kind of stuff we
can't really offer at Stanford
because it is so bleeding edge.
I mean, we announce a new
feature here at Google I/O,
and we already have a
course online where you
can learn how to program this.
That speed cannot be
matched in academia.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So this
nanodegree program, is it free?
Does it cost money?
If I wanted to sign up
today, what do I have to do?
Do I have to have some
background experience?
How do I get started?
SEBASTIAN THURN: So
first of all, it's free.
Udacity's mission is to
democratize education,
and you can't democratize
if you charge money.
So anyone in the world can
study all the content for free
and do any of the projects.
However, to become really
good, you want our feedback.
You want services.
You want mentors.
You want code reviews.
You want some engagement.
And these things cost us
money, so we charge money,
and we charge $200
dollars a month.
Google has very
graciously, in Egypt,
just offering 2,000
scholarships for students
so that students can
get those services
and still study for free.
In terms of prerequisites, if
you've never programmed before,
don't try it.
It's too hard.
If fact, we have a
little test there.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Maybe become a designer?
SEBASTIAN THURN: No no no.
Take a different nanodegree.
Do programming first.
We have a whole bunch of those.
You can start at the very
beginning with Udacity.
But Android is
really meant to be
kind of a proficient,
top-level Android developer,
the same way Google
would hire internally.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Got it.
Got it.
So we kind of
talked a little bit
about how Udacity is going
to help drive job creation.
I heard, when I was talking to
Peter backstage, a little bit
about this career summit.
Can you speak to what the
career summit is and some
of the goals of that?
SEBASTIAN THURN: Yeah.
That's totally cool.
Laszlo Bock and
his team at Google
have decided they're going to
invite 50 of the top Android
finishers for our
nanodegree over to Google
in November, all expenses paid,
for a multiday summit where
we do a hackathon and you
meet Google recruiters,
and possibly a few of
them find Google jobs.
That's a great motivation
to the students in the world
to sign up for it, but
it's also a great sign
that Google is
willing to reconsider
alternative credentials--
in this case, it's
own nanodegree-- alternative
to conventional college
credentials.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And so it's not
even that this is
going to be a long-term goal.
This goal can be
accomplished this year.
SEBASTIAN THURN: It's going
to be accomplished this year.
And think about what's at
stake, how many people we have
in the world who don't
like their job who
can't get a good education.
Like the entire Middle East, for
example, my friend Tom Friedman
talks about that he
believes if there's
good education in
the Middle East,
there'd be fewer terrorists.
Think about mid-career people.
We have stay-at-home moms to
turn into software developers.
We had a professional
golf player
who became a data analyst.
These kind of shifts don't exist
today, and in this work force,
we need paths for those people.
If we do this, humanity
could be twice as productive.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So you spoke about
the Middle East.
I know that your team has
also been working with Google
to enable even more
educational opportunities,
specifically in Egypt.
Can you tell me
a little bit more
and our audience a little
bit more about what's
going on in Egypt?
SEBASTIAN THURN: Google
has a really great
working relationship with
the Egyptian government,
and so do we, by association.
And Google has decided to
translate several courses
that we've jointly built
into Arabic, end to end,
so that a non-English speaking
person could still study
and become a top-notch software
developer, Android developer,
and so on.
And on top of it,
Google is putting
in study centers, job centers,
and stipends for students
to take those materials.
For me, it's great because
I'm passionately following
the sad news in the
Middle East every day
and the entire Arab peninsula.
I truly believe if we
brought good education
to that specific
part of the world,
there'd be alternative
pathways for people
to get a bit of the energy
and do something productive.
And picking Egypt is a great
launching pad because Egypt
is relatively stable,
has an extremely
talented and
inspiring population,
and has a huge number
of women in technology,
as I just learned, which I
think is really important
to bring more women
into technology.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So as I was mentioning, I work
on the Women Techmakers program
here at Google, and
my role is to increase
the visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
And I think so
often, we don't hear
of all the amazing
women globally that
are in the technology industry.
And so specifically, when we're
thinking of the Middle East,
so Arabic is first.
Have you guys started thinking
about what countries you
might go to next?
SEBASTIAN THURN: We have
translated various classes
into up to 40 different
languages when
it comes to subtitling, but the
narrative is still in English.
We currently took
investment from Japan,
from Europe, Germany,
and from Brazil.
We are very heavily
contemplating
China at this point, and we
have a huge following in India.
Udacity is an
international platform.
Our students are mostly
from international countries
from all parts of the world,
and that's our mission,
to be global.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
And when I was talking to
even some women yesterday,
we were talking about
how in order to, I think,
really increase
the participation
and the graduation rate
from these courses,
I think what's really
powerful about what you're
doing is this end
to end translation,
because I think sometimes,
subtitles aren't enough.
The more that we can have
natural language speakers
actually teaching these courses,
it makes it feel-- not just
for women, but I think
for people of any nation,
to have it feel like
it was made for them.
So I think that's a
really cool aspect
of what you're doing in Egypt.
I was telling you a
little bit backstage,
I had the privilege to bring
together a four-woman team
to create the new Android
for Beginners course.
So those are just the women
that are specifically at Google.
There's also a whole
team at Udacity.
And our thought was, how can
we bring anyone anywhere,
regardless of their background,
into the Android ecosystem?
What are your thoughts
around how anyone
can jump in and participate?
Is it starting with Android?
Where do you think
they should begin?
SEBASTIAN THURN: I think
online education is not
to be underestimated
in its power.
It's easy to box people in.
I don't want to
box anybody here,
but I've heard some of our
female students voicing,
look, we feel less intimidated
than in the classroom
with like 90% males
that are all super smart
and raise their hand and makes
us feel slightly inferior.
It gives much more privacy
and much more ability to-- you
can watch the same video 50
times if you want, and so on.
It's also cultural.
I mean, to me, programming
Android is sexy.
It's interesting.
How many billions of
people at this point?
There's 1.5 billion new devices
unlocked every single day.
How can you possibly
be worth more than
if you become an
Android programmer.
We have 3.69 billion unique
mobile accounts in the world.
Half the world is on mobile.
81% is Android.
I think we should
just all move into it,
and we should leave
the old stuff behind.
We're being told,
you can't do it
because of race, ethnicity,
whatever, intellect, gender,
sexual orientation,
that's all wrong.
Just do it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
Well, thanks so
much for joining us.
I really appreciate you taking
the time, and congratulations
on the announcement today.
SEBASTIAN THURN:
Thank you so much.